[موسيقى]
على مبني الرحله التاليه المشاركه التوجه
الى البوابه رقم
[موسيقى]
سبعه وحده الظهر 15 اكتوبر 2015 مطار دمشق
الدولي اشخاص كثير ناطرين طيارتهم توصل
لحتى يسافروا
احلامهم ناطرين باب الفرس يفتح لحتى
تحققوا كل شي ما كانوا عم يقدروا يعملوهم
عالطرف الثاني كنت انا راجع راجعه بعد
رحله سفر طويله ما اخذت منها ولا شي
قرار رجعه كان قرار مفاجئ ما تركلي مجال
عدل فيه الامور اللي عملتها هونيك لاقدر
استفاد منهن مو سهل يقطعك الطريق بنصفه
ويحولك على طريق مختلف تماما
رجعت من الصفر بلا شهاده جامعه لانه ما
لحقت اتخرج بلا حتى شهاده بكالوريا لانه
ما قدرت لو استفاد منها رجعت معهالصندوق
بس
لهلا بتذكر اول موقف مهني ان حطيت بشغل
اول مره رجعت اشتغلت بمنصب اداري بشركه
معينه
بيجي وقتها
انا عم بشرحلو استراتيجيه الشركه لوين
رايحه شو الرؤيه تبعها فبتطلع فيني بقول
لي اوكي عندكم شويه ضعف بالدراسه الماليه
رح اشرح لك اكثر عنها وبيسالني حضرتك
خريجه شو
سؤال عادي وطبيعي وبينسال دائما المشكله
بس وقت ما يكون عندك جواب وبعد كلمه حضرتك
معرفه كذب عليه ولا اقول له انا عمري 19
سنه ما معي شهاده خبرتي كلها على بعضها ما
بتتعدى السنتين والمنصب اللي مستلمته اكبر
مني بشي عشر سنين على الاقل
المشكله ما كانت السؤال وفعلا ما كانت حتى
بانه ما عندي جواب المشكله كانت مني وقت
انا قررت انه هدول هن النقط ضعف مهنيه مع
اني بشكل او باخر كنت قادره اجاوب على ادق
تفصيل بخص الشغل وكان عندي خبره تخليني
مؤهله ناقش وافهم واعكس كل شيء عم ينحكى
بهذا السياق وبدل ما اركز على هدول النقط
اللي بتعزز قوتي لا
ركز على الضعف وبخافوا
مليون فكره براسي
والشعور بالخجل والخوف عم يطغى عليهم كلهم
بالفتره اللي بعدها صرت اركض اركض اتعلم
ادرس اي شيء بيطلع بوجهي بيجي مبرمج على
الشركه برجع على البيت بحضر كورسات برمجه
بيجي ديزاينر على المكتب برجع بسهر طول
الليل اتعلم تصميم مشان ثاني يوم اشرحلو
شو بدي بمصطلحات طبعا هذا الشيء امتدعى كل
شيء مجالات وكل شيء موظفين جبناهم بالشركه
لدرجه ما عاد مفهوم انا شو بشتغل وشو
شاطره
هذا الشيء كان جدا متعب وكانت هاي النقط
عم تعزز عندي اكثر المشكله اني كنت ضايعه
ما بعرف وينها حدود الخبره اللي فيني
ارسمها ما بعرف ايمت طبيعي وعادي اقول ما
بعرف ايمت فيني اقول هذا مو اختصاصي رح
دور وبرجعلك بجواب كان بالنسبه لي اذا
انسالت عشيه ومعرفه تجاوب فهو اكيد لانه
انا ما بعرف اشتغل وماني شاطر
ومع شعور الخجل والخوف اللي عندي صار معهم
شعوري
كنت ماسكه هي المشاعر وحاططا عجنب خبيتهم
عامله حالي ماني شايف
وقت تكون مبلش شغل بعمر صغير 16 سنه مثلا
بتضطر تتعامل مع مشاعر مختلفه ومرعبه بشكل
طبيعي نقاط ضعفك المهنيه على الاقل بتكون
كبيره مقارنه بالاشخاص الاكبر سنا والاكثر
خبره اللي حواليك
وغالبا ما بيكون عندك القدره والوعي
الكافي للتعامل معهم صح فمنبلش نخبي
ونتخبى نخبي شو عنا مشاكل وثغرات ونتخبى
انه اي حدا يشوفنا ويشوف شو عم نعمل
بحياتنا من خوفنا ليكشفنا على فرضيه انه
باقي الاشخاص مثاليين واحسن منا بكثير
فمنضيع الفرص اللي كان فينا نعكس فيها
خبراتنا مواقع قوتنا
عيش التجارب بهذه الفتره كانت جدا مرعبه
وصعبه وهذا الصندوق كان عم يتعزز اكثر
فاخذت قرار واضح وحاسم اني اقضي على كل ما
الضعف اللي عندي اكيد بتعرفوا متخيلين انه
نهايه هذا القرار ما كانت نتيجه لانه على
الاقل وقتها ما كنت رح وقف هون اشرحلكم عن
رجعت للدراسه قضيت ما يقارب 18 ساعه يوميا
ادرس لقدام بكالوريا وخاصه اني عم اعوض
سنين دراستي برا اللي هي مختلفه عن الشيء
اللي بدي اعمله
واحده من اهم نقاط الضعف الشخصيه اللي
عندي
اني ما بعرف احفظ
بدي ضعف المده اللي بده اياها اي شخص تاني
لا قدر اوصل لنصف النتيجه اللي
قدرت اخذ البكالوريا وبلشت دور على مجال
جامعه يتناسب مع اهتماماتي
للاسف هذا القرار ما بيكون قرارك بشكل
كامل بكون مرتبط بشو عنا فروع بالبلد
مجموعه شو باهلك تدرس وكثير روابط تانيه
ولا وحده منهم انت شو شغفك او شو بتحب
تعمل
فباول سنه بالجامعه
من الاحساس
عم بدرس اكاديميه عن شي وعم بلش اشتغل على
مسار وظيفه مختلف
وما كنت بعرف قديه هاي القصه هي حتاثر علي
كل ما اطلع وشوف انا قديش عندي نقص كل ما
اتجاهلوا اكثر كل ما صير عم بركض اكثر
وتصير كل شي انجازات عم بعملها انا ما عم
حس فيها شو يعني درست شو يعني اخذت بورصه
شو يعني ترفعت واخدت منصب اعلى كانت فتره
جدا مرعبه وقفت
وقلت لحالي انا بعرف قديش انت عم تتعبي
بعرف قديش عم تبزلي جهد وقفي شوي ارتاحي
ارجعي بلشي من الاول ارجعي حددي اهدافك
حددي شو عندك ضعف لتوصلي لهذه الاهداف
عن بالغ وقت بقول انه هي كانت نقطه تحول
مفصليه بحياتي فكرت بكل شعور سلبي مرعي
بكل نقطه ضعف واجهته ووقفتني عن اني انجز
انا اليوم ممتنه ممتنه لكل نقاط الضعف
اللي كانوا عندي واللي عندي حاليا ممتنه
للخوف للفشل لو قله الخبره حتى الاضافي
بالحفظ الدراسه لانه ما في اي حافز خارجي
بالعالم ممكن يعطيك نفس الدافع والقوه
اللي انت بتعطيه لحالك داخليا اليوم وقت
استلم منصب وتشوف شغلي عم ينعرض فخوره
فخوره جدا لانه بعرف انه الطريق ابدا ما
كان سهل كان كله مشاعر مخيفه كان وما زال
مليء بالضعف بكل خطوه
تاخرت لك اكتشفت انه انا فيني اخبي نقاط
ضعفي حتى قدام حالي بس فعليا انا ما ببطل
احس فيهم ما فيني اقول يلا هاي كل شي
سلبيه هي مشاعر الخوف والضعف والخجل راح
امسكهن وحطهم هون ما راح حسبي ولا شيء
منهم راح اقوم اعمل فنجان قهوه واتابع
مسلسل لا مو هيك طبيعي وضروري بمراحل
حياتك انت وعم تكبر بتحس بشغلات مخربطه
وسلبيه احيانا لانه باللحظه اللي من بطل
نحس فيها بهاي المشاعر رح يبطل عنا قدرا
نحس باي شيء معاكس راح نبطل نحس بالتقدير
هاد الصندوق اللي بيمثل كل نقاط الضعف
ومشاعر الخوف بحياتي كل حدا فيكن عنده
صندوق مثله
كان لازم افتحه وواجهه لا قادر اوصل لاخر
ورقه فيه واللي هي الامل
[تصفيق]